αυτό το κάναμε το κοσίδιο κάναμε μία μεγάλει ψηφιακή μεταρήσυη συντοποσηδί ώστε να βάλουμε κάποια
εργαλία τα οποία ένα μπορεί ο κόσμος να κάνει τη δουλειά του πολύ περισότεροψηφιακά νομίζω
έν ένα βήμα τώρα έχουμε το αια παραδειγμα το οποίο εσημαντικό επίσης επιπλέον εργαλίο που
πρέπει να εντάξουμε στη σχέση μας με τους πελάτες θα το κάνει καιο ανταγωνισμός οπότε
μονόδρομος οπότε αναμένουν φαντάζομε τώρα η νέι ινέα γενιά αναμένει από τι σίδα να προσαργότης
με ς προσδογίες τους όποιος το κάνει καλύτερα θα κερδείσει περισσότερος ιεμείς ευελπιστούμε ότι θα
είμαστε εμείς πολύ δουλιά δουλειά δουλειά λέμε συνέχεια για τον αντριάνεοκλές υπάρχει κάτι που των
ιρεεμεί στην καθημέα του κάτι άλλο εκτ από τη σίδακαθημερινεότηταμο ναι εκείταοι καθημεραίδαίουμε έχει πολύσια
νομίζω δεν θα έλεγα ότι δεν είμαι ύρεμος όμως με την καθημεριονόδηράμο στης δα θέλω
να πω για να με δίκαιος η δουλειά μου αρέσει πάρα πολύ και μου δίνει
πάρα πολ ευχαρίστηση το αντικείμενο της δουλειάς μουνμίζω όταν κάποτε φίο πό τις υδα δε
θα είμαι τόσο ύρεμος όσον είμαι τώρα πάρα πολλά ωραία οι δουλειά και σίγουρα έχω
και πράγματα εκτός δουλεις τα οποία με ιρεμούν αλλά θα έλεγα ότι δεν δεν έχω
λόγους να ψάχνω ιρεμεια εκτός δουλειάς λίγον ξεκούρασεις μερικές φορές γι ότι πολλές φορές τι
συνεκείς συναντίσεις λίώσει σε κάμνουν τρέιν αφερούν τσι λίο που τις διάδειά ντα ξεα γώ
είμε τις σάλας σας μεγάλος α λεμεσόν τρπάφωνο πότε